le peuple chinois ne veut pas traiter
après la répression qui a fait des
milliers de morts pékin continue de
résister à l'armée des centaines de
milliers d'iraniens ont rendu un dernier
hommage à khomeini la dre succession de
l'ayatollah s'annonce difficile
édition spéciale d'actualité jusqu'à 21h
sur la chine et sur l'iran le nombre
d'invités au tour de christine ockrent
pour comprendre les événements
solidarité triomphe les premiers
résultats des élections polonaises donc
une large victoire aux amis de lech
walesa
sensation à roland garros le numéro un
mondial ivan lendl sortie par ce jeune
américain de vie s'étant michael chang
bonsoir en chine le spectre de la guerre
civile se dessine désormais dimanche la
répression a fait vous le savez des
milliers de morts on parle de 3000
maintenant mais cette répression de
l'armée n'a pas fait taire la révolte
des étudiants et de toute la population
plusieurs faits font craindre
aujourd'hui qu'une véritable guerre
civile ne se déclenche ce lundi par
exemple à pékin on a vu des soldats se
battent entre eux ceux qui répriment et
ceux qui ne veulent pas continuer le
massacre et il y à eut lancé d'autres
manifestations d'autres révol dans
toutes les grandes villes du pays
et tout au long de cette journée la
population de la capitale chinoise a
poursuivi sa résidence martin laroche
joubert
l'homme est seul en chemisette blanche
les mains nues face à six blindés par la
seule force de sa témérité
il réussit à les stopper plus loin un
autre en matant à eux deux ils
symbolisent toute la résistance du
peuple de pékin face aux massacres
organisés par le 27e corps d'armée qui a
ouvert le feu dans la nuit de samedi
des morts et des blessés par milliers il
devient de plus en plus difficile
mais à pékin les journalistes sont
pourchassés et des documents d'amateurs
comme celui ci via la détermination des
pikinois or ils attaquent les camions de
l'armée et ne se retire que sous les
cookies ville sous haute surveillance
l'armee se déploie aujourd'hui encore
dans pk et tirs tandis que les
ambassades demandent à leurs
ressortissants étrangers d'observer la
plus grande prudence
mais à la prudence les chinois préfèrent
le défi et choisissent la colère ils
viennent d'attaquer dans le centre ville
un pull bois depuis de 80 camions qui
rejoignait la place tiananmen quadrillée
par les blasés ici les soldats n'ont pas
tiré et ont fui abandonnant leurs
véhicules
signe du désarroi d'une partie de
l'armée
par ailleurs sur ce carrefour
stratégique près de la place tiananmen
des centaines de soldats prennent
position dans les camions des
manifestants arrêtés violence de la
répression mais solidarité des grandes
villes chinoises
à shanghai les étudiants appellent à la
grève générale bloquent les rues érigent
des barricades d'armes aux chinois et
d'autres sanctions économiques pourrait
suivre jacquat bouchard tout de suite à
washington
les ventes d'armes américaines à la
chine sont suspendues a nommé george
bush donnent un coup d'arrêt à toute
coopération militaire entre les deux
pays
c'est donc la riposte du président des
etats-unis qui a publiquement condamné
l' usage de la force et l'effusion de
sang à pégase george bush avait appelé
les dirigeants chinois au dialogue
en recevant récemment monsieur wang li
président de l'assemblée nationale
chinoise
il exclut de couper les ponts avec pékin
où il s'était rendu quelques semaines
après son installation à la maison
blanche
dans un premier temps il n'y aura donc
pas de sanctions commerciales
américaines contre la chine à washington
des milliers de manifestants se sont
rassemblés pendant 48 heures devant
l'ambassade de chine pour protester
contre la répression
il s'agissait en majorité d'étudiants
inscrits dans les universités
américaines
george bush a d'ailleurs décidé qu'il
pourrait obtenir une prolongation de
leur séjour aux états unis si le soit
un pressions continues sur pékin mais
pas de rupture c'est la ligne de la
maison blanche
il ne s'agit pas d'accuser les
dirigeants chinois de les pousser à se
recroqueviller dans leur coquille mais
plutôt de leur faire comprendre
fermement que la seule issue à la crise
actuelle est un retour à la modération à
l'esprit de réforme et surtout au
dialogue
l'europe aussi réagi le président de la
commission européenne jacques delors
annulé une rencontre prévue avec un
ministre chinois au sein de la
communauté on commence aussi à réagir et
à parler de sanctions réaction du côté
du marché des marchés financiers aussi
la bourse de hong kong par exemple a
perdu 22% en une seule séance c'est sa
baisse la plus importante depuis le
krach d'octobre 87
et puis enfin le ministère français des
affaires étrangères recommande d'
annuler maintenant tous les voyages en
chine et les tour opérateurs ont tout de
suite suivi cette recommandation en
annulant effectivement tous les voyages
qu'ils étaient tous les voyages
touristiques qui était prévu en chine
ces jours ci nous allons revenir dans un
instant sur ce qui se passe en chine
dans notre esprit dans d'autres éditions
spéciales mais nous y parlerons aussi de
l'iran car la mort de l'ayatollah
khomeini le maître de l'iran depuis dix
ans pourrait bien déclencher un séisme
de grande envergure dans cette région du
monde aussi aujourd'hui à téhéran les
iraniens rendait un dernier hommage à
leur chef religieux qui c'était un
samedi soir à 87 ans des centaines de
milliers d'iraniens se sont bousculés il
ya même eu des morts et des blessés
patricia cost civile exprime aujourd'hui
les iraniens
ce qu'on appelle les déshérités semble
avoir perdu jusqu'à l'espoir avec la
mort de l'ayatollah khomeini depuis hier
soir venu du pays entier
ils convergent par centaines de milliers
dans la mosquée mots sales là pour
approcher et voir une dernière fois
l'imam guide suprême de la révolution
rappelons le pèlerinage à la mecque
la foule s'est rituellement mise à
tourner autour du catafalque dressé au
centre de la mosquée difficilement
acheminés à 6h ce matin le corps de nag
et au delà dans un cercueil de verre est
ainsi offert à la vénération des fidèles
les bousculades et mystery aggravée par
la fatigue et la chaleur ont déjà
provoqué la mort de plusieurs personnes
cinq cents autres ayant été blessés venu
pour dire adieu à celui qu'ils appellent
leur père ils resteront ici des nuits
entières rejoints par d'autres pour
vivre les funérailles qui auront lieu
demain si le successeur de l'imam est à
présent désigné
il lui reste encore à s'attirer mais à
canaliser aussi la passion de ces
orphelins frénétique et alors que l'iran
prépare les funérailles de l'ayatollah
khomeini son successeur a été désigné
dès hier briller de l'air vous disais il
s'agit du président ali khamenei un
homme qui se retrouve maintenant au
centre d'une situation politique très
très confuse la succession de kameni est
vraiment compliqué michel mots comptés
il aura fallu plus de huit heures de
délibérations à cette assemblée des
experts pour se rendre compte d'une
évidence
l'ayatollah khomeini ne peut pas être
remplacé
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils ont
choisi ali khamenei l'actuel président
de la république un homme sans envergure
une élection qui illustre parfaitement
le vide spirituel et politique laissé
par l'imam
dans la hiérarchie religieuse ali
khamenei n'occupe une opposition mineurs
il n'a même pas le titre ayatollahs une
élection qui a toutes les apparences
d'une solution provisoire dans un moment
de crise et le régime break tellement de
garde est une façade des régimes il est
nommé comme successeur de là et là je
vous assure que dans quelques jours il
donnera sa place à quelqu'un d'autre
c'est à dire que ne pas place à
quelqu'un d'autre et sans gras c'est en
effet ce qui pourrait bien se passer et
ce pour deux raisons
depuis son élection à la présidence de
la république il y a huit ans ali
khamenei s'est surtout montré discret à
l'extrême il n'a jamais cherché à
prendre l'ombre d'une décision politique
il serait bien étonnant qu'il le fasse
aujourd'hui la deuxième raison c'est la
présence derrière ali khamenei d'un
homme qui lui dicterait en fait tous ses
actes hashemi rafsanjani il à lui trois
atouts dans les mains l'armé les très
puissants gardiens de la révolution et
la radio la télévision iranienne que
dirige son frère il sera de plus le seul
candidat à l'élection présidentielle du
18 août prochain
il sera donc vraisemblablement élu
autant dire que l'on pourrait bien
assister en iran dans les mois qui
viennent un glissement de la nature du
régime
le pouvoir spirituel c'est façon peu à
peu au profit de ce pouvoir politique
celui de rafsanjani le pouvoir absolu
incarné par khomeiny semble bel et bien
avoir vécu et en raison de ces
événements en iran et en chine deux
événements de portée considérable vous
l'avez compris antenne 2 a modifié ses
programmes ce soir c'est à 21h que
débutera l'émission de jean marie cavada
interdit d'innocence une émission
consacrée aux droits de l'enfant
je vous le disais en titre aussitôt
après ce journal et jusqu'à 21h donc la
rédaction d'antenne 2 vous propose une
édition spéciale
christine ockrent vous allez tenter de
voir avec vos invités de comprendre un
peu la portée tous ces événements oui
parce qu'il faut bien dire que ce sont
deux événements qui n'ont rien en commun
sauf les coïncidence du calendrier est
aussi la force de l'image de cette image
qui nous provient presqu'immédiatement
de pékin comme de terreau en reste
encore a expliqué
à essayer de comprendre c'est ce que
nous allons essayer de faire tout à
l'heure avec des experts des
commentateurs nous on seront aussi en
duplex de washington de hong kong
seule déception moscou nous n'avons
trouvé aucun interlocuteur il semble
qu'à moscou les soviétiques n'ai pas
envie ce soir de commenter ce qui se
passe en chine et non plus à téhéran
merci christine a tout de suite avec vos
invités mais l'actualité est très riche
ce soir car il y encore par exemple les
élections en pologne
c'étaient les premières élections libres
organisées depuis longtemps dans ce pays
solidarité présenter des candidats vous
le savez et pour eux c'est un véritable
triomphe tout au moins d'après les
premiers résultats les résultats
définitifs mettront plusieurs jours à
être connu jacques merino tout de suite
à varsovie les premiers résultats
collectés à varsovie aujourd'hui ont
laissé la foule sans voix devant les
bureaux de solidarnosc
on fait les comptes et l'on n'en revient
pas sauf surprise venant de quelques
régions reculées il semble bien en effet
que la victoire de solidarnosc soit
totale sur les 100 sièges du sénat
le syndicat de lech walesa emporterait
98 mandat et plus de 150
sur les 161 sièges réservés aux
indépendants à la chambre des députés
je pense que les gouvernements la bâtie
ne connaît pas les vrais sentiments
donation du pop de te plus le vrai
opinion ils se sont séparés
voilà le résultat mais est-ce que ce
matin celui d'un homme
on est très heureux ou est ce qu'on
n'est pas un petit peu inquiets de
l'ampleur de la victoire ray avec un peu
d'inquiétude parce que c'est trop vous
savez il fait maintenant il faut
maintenant consommer tout ça est ce ça
peut être un peu dangereux vous savez ça
vous fait une
situation politique tout à fait
différente non ya pas de réaction de
joie de la foule comment ça se fait bon
on est un peu fatigués on peut c'est pas
la joie de chez pas de sauter de de cris
et pas les gens se rejoignent si vous
voyez combien de combien bien violent si
ça c'est un rebond que moigne âge
c'est un nouveau jour pour la pologne
on verra bien on verra bien est ce que
maintenant vous souhaiter que le
gouvernement s'en aille
ce sport nous sommes pas capables notre
propre gouvernement
quant au parti communiste il se tait le
comité central siège à huis clos et la
conférence de presse que devait tenir le
porte-parole du gouvernement a été
annulé avec nous aux côtés de jacques
merlino à varsovie bronislaw geremek en
duplex et en direct de varsovie monsieur
geremek je vous le rappelle est l'un des
leaders de solidarité est l'un des
conseillers les plus proches de l'aicb
et les arts monsieur geremek bonsoir
alors est ce que les premiers résultats
donc qu'on a eue de varsovie et de toute
la pologne qui sont des résultats
provisoires je le rappelle qui donne une
large victoire au candidat de solidarité
est ce que ça ne dépasse pas vos
prévisions les plus optimistes
d'une certaine façon oui ça dépasse nos
prévisions nous avons pensé que la
participation dans les élections
serra plus grande qu'elle ne l'était en
réalité ils ne vont pas pensé d'obtenir
autant de sièges au sénat et à la diète
mais maintenant il faut encore attendre
les résultats définitifs
nous savons à peu près maintenant que
solidarité a obtenu le soutien de la
société polonaise total alors reçu qu'un
remake le premier ministre le mythe
intérieur le misra défense les
principaux personnes les principales
priorités du parti crise sont battus
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement polonais actuelle peut
rester en place
ou est-ce que vous souhaiter sa
démission j'ai l'impression que vous me
posez une question qui reste en dehors
des réalités politiques polonaises
nous ne vivons pas dans un régime
parlementaire et démocratique
nous vivons dans un régime dans lequel
le parlement avait toujours un rôle
plutôt secondaire
nous avons obtenu à la table ronde un
contrat politique c'est un contrat
politique qui donnait la majorité au
parti communiste qui détient le pouvoir
depuis quarante cinq ans et nous allons
tenir notre parole
le contrat est là 65 % de sièges au
parlement
serra dans les mains du parti communiste
il se trouve que sur la liste nationale
qui fait partie de ces 65 % il y a des
leaders actuels du parti et par une
erreur monumentale des reins la loi
électorale
à cette liste qui devrait être un indice
prix villégier ne donnait pas là le
droit au second tour comme tous les
autres candidats dont tous les autres
candidats disposent et de ce fait là
au premier tour la liste nationale
risque de ne pas passer et ensuite on
peut dire que le pouvoir et les jeunes
euros et les ministres détiennent ne
vient pas du parlement n'était pas
investi par le parlement mais tout
d'abord par les comité central de leur
parti je pense qu'on trouvera une
solution politique insulaire et mettre
dans le même temps en chine il ya c'est
vrai des événements très graves on en a
parlé au début du journal or je sais que
vous avez peut-être d'autres
préoccupations mais que vous inspire
tout de même ces événements chine en ce
moment en face de cette tragédie qui a
lieu en chine
tout d'abord il ya le sentiment de
révolte les sentiments de solidarité à
l'égard de ceux qui luttent pour la
liberté et j'ai l'impression que les
polonais plus encore que tous les autres
sont solidaires avec ceux qui tombent
maintenant victime de l'introduction de
la loi martiale à tel durcissement est
possible en avoir suivi vous craignez un
durcissement la situation on peut dire
que d'une certain façon dans notre
système dans le gie sienne que miss les
durcissements sont contagieux mais
j'espère peut aussi bien en chine on
trouvera une solution politique qu'en
pologne
on essayera de continuer la table ronde
qui était un événement politique du tout
premier importance
ou pour toutes ces précisions et ses
commentaires sur les élections en pole à
une voyons maintenant d'autres
informations en france et à l'étranger
avec un résumé des principaux faits de
ce lundi à commencer par cette terrible
tragédie en union soviétique cette
catastrophe ferroviaire
éric perrin 190 morts 272 disparus c'est
le premier bilan détaillé de la
catastrophe ferroviaire provoqué par
l'explosion d'un gazoduc en urss mikhaïl
gorbatchev qui a décrété une journée de
deuil national a dénoncé l'incompétence
et l'irresponsabilité une très forte
odeur de gaz était en effet perceptible
avant le drame mais rien n'a été
entrepris pour localiser la fuite au
moins 250 morts et plus de cent
cinquante mille sans abri au sri lanka
des pluies torrentielles ont provoqué
inondations et glissements de terrain
les opérations de secours se poursuivent
françois mitterrand visite officielle de
deux jours en tunisie accueilli par son
homologue le président ben ali le chef
de l'état français a reçu un accueil
chaleureux des tunisiens à l'image des
relations entre les deux pays
les entretiens ont porté sur la
situation au proche orient
on se dirige par ailleurs vers un accord
aux termes duquel antenne 2 sera diffusé
sur le territoire tunisien en politique
français sachez simplement que c'est
demain à 16 heures que sera discuté la
motion de censure déposée par
l'opposition l'udf et le rpr contre la
politique d'immigration du gouvernement
nouveau coup de tonnerre à roland garros
sierra gaci et sabatini avait été sortie
du tournoi et bien aujourd'hui c'est le
favori des favoris qui a été éliminé
ivan lendl lui-même superstar a dû céder
devant les coups d'un garçon de 17 ans
michael chang américain après un match
dramatique en cinq sets
jean ma mère d'habitude quand on vient
exulte de joie michael chang lui tu
pleures
d'habitude quand on gagne
on lève les bras michael chang hui
s'écroule sur le court d'habitude quand
on reçoit une balle de match en se met
au fond mais coup de poker chang lui se
met au milieu du court et provoque chez
lidl la double faute qui lui donne le
match
pourtant ce petit américain a joué le
dernier set à l'énergie épuisé au point
de ne presque plus pouvoir marcher et
encore moins courir à tel point qu'au
dernier changement de côté il préfère
rester debout de peur de ne plus pouvoir
se relever pour provoquer lendl il
n'hésite pas à servir à la cuillère est
encore plus incroyable à faire péter le
numéro un manga il se demande alors s'il
n'est pas tombé sur la tête foule en
deuil sans doute mais stupide surtout
face à un joueur à bout de force et
proche de l'abandon
il ne trouve rien de mieux que de jouer
sur le coup favorites sans adversaire le
revers pour michael chang
au milieu de cette tourmente la solution
cet après-midi était ailleurs
j'espérais bien que dieu que
jésus-christ soit avec moi et me ferait
sortir de ce match
le calvaire s'est terminée après 4
heures 40 de jeu avec un ivan lendl fou
de rage un central debout pour acclamer
sa nouvelle coqueluche michael chang
étonnant non dont je dois vous donner
encore quelques résultats de roland
garros je vais pas tous vous les donner
mais sachez tout de même que le
soviétique chesnau cov vient de se
qualifier pour les quarts de finale il a
battu l'américain jim courir celui là
même qui avait éliminé hier andré agassi
donc c'est chez snopkov qui disputera
les quarts de finale et puis auparavant
ronald agenor l'haïtien avait battu
l'espagnol bruguera pour lui aussi une
place en quarts de finale en cyclisme
charly mottet a remporté qu'elle
dauphiné libéré à l'issue de la 8e étape
8e et dernière étape qui avait été
gagnée par le belge de clerck
laurent fignon lui gardent toujours le
maillot rose du tour d'italie
mais il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui l'étape
avait été annulée alors demain il y à un
tiercé c'est à chantilly je vous propose
tout risque de voir les pronostics de
pierrette brès pour ce tiercé de
chantilly las le 9 le 16 le 6 le 5 le 8
le 7 et le 3 voilà je vous ai laissé le
temps de noter maintenant un autre temps
d'une pause le temps d'une pause
publicitaire et puis un coup d'oeil sur
la météo avec sophie davant et puis nous
revenons tout de suite à l'actualité
importante du jour la chine et l'iran
pour notre édition spéciale sur les
événements de ces deux pays
avec christine ockrent